going together
pressure streak
what does it take to transform the
familiar if a new game armed you with a
standard array of weapons put you in the
kind of rundown villages and industrial
landscapes you've seen a dozen times
before and ask you to shoot your enemies
defend a location or capture a flag how
could that game be anything but overly
familiar it would have to change
something major something with the power
to affect every aspect of the game
something like movement titanfall
reinvents player movement and in doing
so reinvents what it feels like to play
a competitive shooter the freedom to
leap climb and run along walls elevates
Titan Falls fast-paced combat too
thrilling Heights and this freewheeling
action intertwines beautifully with the
brutish tactical Titan battles titanfall
is a leap forward for shooters a game
that combines the vibrant and new with
the tried and true to create something
special the key to titanfall success is
mobility the way you maneuver through
the environments as a jump pack equipped
pilot it starts with double jumping on
two shipping crates and in two
second-story windows and moves on to
running along walls and leaping around
corners these moves are completely
dependent on the angle of your approach
and the timing of your jumps so it's
easy to get the hang of the basics as
you develop a sense for how your pilot
sticks to walls you can string together
more and more complex acrobatics
this makes simply moving around the map
both a continual pleasure and a constant
challenge as you gleefully try to
exploit every billboard building and
zipline to your advantage
the 15 diverse maps are all rich with
opportunities for creative locomotion
it's always empowering to learn the maps
in a competitive shooter but this
satisfaction is heightened in titanfall
because you're expanded mobility means
there is so much more to learn it also
means your enemies can come at you from
almost any direction brandishing one of
the fairly standard weapons or maybe the
novel auto-locking smart pistol add to
this the ability to turn almost
invisible to boost speed or to see
enemies through walls and you have a lot
of strategic considerations when
engaging foes which is more deadly a
speeding wall runner rapidly closing
distance or a cloaked enemy wall hanging
above a doorway and waiting to pounce
enemy pilots make for
opponents but the AI grunts that deploy
into combat are more like cannon fodder
they don't pose much of a threat as long
as you don't try to kick your way
through a large group of them but in
addition to making battles feel more
populated grunts service targets of
opportunity to help you level up unlock
weapon attachments and reduce your Titan
build time because in titanfall
everybody gets it Titan
and every Titan is a force to be
reckoned with armed with an array of
offensive and defensive weapons Titans
present an entirely different kind of
combat one in which shield management
use of cover and properly timed salvos
of explosive ordnance decide the victor
these slower more prolonged clashes
offer a refreshing contrast to the
speedy pilot firefights but don't think
that these two exist independently of
each other pilots can bombard Titans
from afar or hop on their backs like
mischievous monkeys Titans in turn can
punch squash and blow up pilots with
ease provided they can get a bead on
them and herein lies the magic of
titanfall two very distinct types of
combat expertly balanced and intertwines
to create chaotic conflicts brimming
with opportunities for incredible
emergent moments though titanfall
actually does tell a story within the
campaign multiplayer mode the reason you
play this multiplayer only shooter is
the stories you make yourself and with
so many clever mechanics and enticing
strategies to play with you're gonna
have some great titanfall stories to
tell